mon coeur on me l'a confectionné le jour
de ma naissance
on dit que je suis née le jour le plus
froid du monde et que mon coeur a gelé
c'est un peu bricolé mais ça marche
allez christophe colomb prêt pour la
découverte jeux mobiles java
il y a trois règles que tu ne devra
jamais oublier ne pas toucher à mes
aiguilles jury mais aussi maîtriser sa
colère je sais mon coeur ressemble à un
jouet nom ne doit pas jouer avec et la
troisième
tu ne devra jamais tomber amoureux
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit d'abba
tunisair après en train dé du couvent et
quelque chose toi tu sais bien que c'est
interdit
qu'est ce que tu lui as fait il connaît
pas une jambe dans ce minuscule qui se
cognent partout elle s'appelle miss
acacias et personne n'a le droit de
parler d'elle sauf moi n'est tout de
même pas tombé amoureux d'elle toi aussi
un peu
savais tu méliès j'ai rencontré une
petite chanteuse jours de show girl
oui mais quand je les ai vus j'ai eu
très peur que mon coeur s'arrête tu as
envie de vivre la grande aventure avec
ce qui je crois que l'état grenade
jamais autant ri fabuleux vaucher
moi qui vit avec une horloge donc
je pense que si art de bouquets de lunel
ce ne sont pas les fleurs préférées
c'est une faillite tout en talons
aiguilles curd capitule et les têtes un
homme alors
qui se dérèglent est pas à moi ou comme
toujours je m'attendais affronter un
adversaire plus coriace
tu ne la méritent vraiment pas
ont-ils
eaubonne
miss acacias